this 14 year old girl described by her
family as thoughtful and caring took her
own life five years ago but in a
landmark conclusion the cause of death
recorded by the coroner was not suicide
instead he stated Molly Rose Russell
died from an act of self-harm whilst
suffering from depression and the
negative effects of online content he
said the platform's algorithms
romanticized acts of self-harm
normalized her condition and that some
content discouraged discussion with
those who may have been able to help
ultimately contributing to her death
if this demented trail of life-sucking
content was safe my daughter Molly would
probably still be alive it's time to
protect our innocent young people
instead of allowing platforms to
prioritize their profits by monetizing
the misery of young people
those platforms have today responded
meta who own Instagram told Sky News
we're committed to ensuring that
Instagram is a positive experience for
everyone particularly teenagers and
Pinterest said we've invested in
building new technologies that
automatically identify and take action
on self-harm content most of the
hundreds of posts shown in quarter too
distressing to broadcast but essentially
glorified suicide the inquest heard how
one email she received from Pinterest
was headed 10 depression pins you might
like accompanied with a picture of a
razor blade
and Molly isn't the only one Alicia
Cowie was 13 when she started
self-harming after algorithms on
Instagram introduced her to it I didn't
need to know what suicide was or how to
do it properly
um because that was just feeding into
the fact that I wanted to do it and
maybe if I didn't see these images I
wouldn't have even thought about it
Children's Charities say this verdict
should send shock waves through Silicon
Valley already preparing itself for how
the government's Online safety bill
should impose stricter measures on
protecting users from harmful content or
mean they face fines the question is
whether or not this inquest might
actually be more effective in triggering
action opening the floodgates of people
launching litigation against the big
Tech firms for mental health conditions
the current are very sensitively put
social media Platforms in the place
today and said it's not good enough that
this contributes to people's death but
there's hope here as well have
conversations with your kids have
conversations with each other about how
to engage with young people to protect
them from the harm on and offline
for those who loved her it's been the
longest of Journeys thank you Molly for
being my daughter for the Russell family
this marks a moment of closure in their
battle to expose the dangers of social
media in Molly's death was the greatest
of warnings and in this verdict the big
Tech was the most damning of judgments
Katie Spencer Sky News